-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
we're here with
Tracee Ellis Ross.
I do ask this question often of
people who figure --
or I should say finish long runs
on beloved shows --
did you,
I don't want to say stole,
did you liberate anything
from the set?
-Yeah, I, um I asked to liberate
a piece of art
that had been on the wall,
it has not made it to me.
I am still under the hopeful
idea that it will show up
at my door in a package.
I don't think I got
the piece of art I wanted.
I did, however, take as much
wardrobe as I possibly
could fit in my car.
because Bow Johnson
had a great wardrobe.
And at one point I was, like,
loading the back of my car
and an ABC executive walked by
and I was like,
"Either turn around
or know that I am helping
the wardrobe department
and I'm bringing
these things to the cleaners.
They are -- the cleaners is on
the way home
and I just want to help them out
to get all this stuff cleaned up
so you can pack it up.
-[ Laughs ]
That was very, very kind.
You're a, you know,
you're a very charitable person.
-Awful.
I'm sure he bought that,
hook, line, and sinker.
-Absolutely. And you know what,
everybody knows that about me.
I'm helpful.
-Very helpful.
Now, this is a time to embark on
new experiences,
when you wrap something like
this up.
I've heard tell that the next
frontier for you might be
trying stand up out,
is this true?
-It's a hope, it's a dream,
it's a wish.
I don't, I think -- okay --
it's clearly so much harder
than the greats, you know who
I'm looking at, Seth,
than y'all make it seem.
-[ Laughs ]
-But I'm looking for
a tight five.
-Alright. Well now --
-Isn't that the term?
Is that the term?
-Tight five, yeah.
Is you can get a tight five
you're on your way.
-Oh, okay.
All of a sudden it sounded
like I said something sexual.
[ Both laugh ]
-Or, like, what I'm supposed to
achieve at the end of my diet.
Like a tight five.
-There's a different kind --
there's a different of, like,
people that will
will want a different kind of
tight five.
Just steer clear of it.
-Okay. Right. Okay.
So we don't want -- so will you
tell me what the top three
things are that I should think
about with stand up?
-Oh, that's a very --
that's a good question.
I mean, it has to be things you
enjoy
that brings you joy
to say them out loud.
-Okay.
-Like, I think that people
can tell when you're not joyous
about it.
-That's a good note.
-I think that in your head,
your tight five is probably,
at first writing, gonna be 10 or
15 minutes, right?
Like, it will, you have to be --
-This is getting harder
by the minute.
-Yes, but it'll,
like, you just have to be,
you know, sort of ruthless
at the editing of it.
-Okay.
-And lastly, uh...
I would just say they can smell
your fear.
So, you know. Don't have it.
-Well it's gonna be --
It's gonna be
a stinky room, Seth.
[ Both laugh ]
-Well, no you did something
harder than a tight five.
-What?
-So I saw this photograph.
You took, you managed to get
your entire family,
including your mother
Diana Ross, to wear
the same matching pajamas and
take this Christmas photo.
I mean, this is -- when I look
at the amount of people here,
I cannot believe this was pulled
off, it's a beautiful photo.
-Not only -- well, my sister
Rhonda is not in the photo.
Not only was it pulled off,
but I during the holidays,
am in charge of food and photos.
-Okay.
-So I usually will cut --
I don't have children
so I have really strong
assignments.
And this Christmas I was like
I'm not ruining this.
I literally shipped my
Ring Light home.
So I shipped my Ring Light
and my tripod home.
We used to do family photos
where my mom would, like,
we would go to a costume shop,
and like, do Victorian costumes.
But there's so many children and
so many husbands and wives now,
we're like 22, that it's like
Amazon pajamas.
And we got everyone in the
photo.
And my family, it's,
there's noth--
I just, I like and love
my family so much.
And the holidays are, like,
our favorite time
to be holed up in the house
together.
And, yeah, that photo's a good
capture of it.
-I think the very wise thing you
did is, I noticed,
some of the younger people were
allowed to have bicycles?
-Yeah.
-That's very smart.
In regard to keeping their
attention.
Let 'em have the bikes.
-Well, let 'em have the bikes.
Let 'em look at --
I mean, the whole beginning
of taking a photo is like,
"This way, this way, ha ha ha!
This way, this way. Look over
here. Look over --
Everlee look --
Everlee look over here."
You do that for, like,
10 minutes
and then you finally get
a photo.
But my trick is I have a little
remote, in my hand.
And I just snap and snap and
snap and snap and snap.
And then we have to go through,
like, 45 pictures.
-Well, I -- let me just say that
there are 22 of you
and at least 15 of you are
looking at the camera.
So great job.
-[ Laughs ] Thank you.
-Hey, thanks for being here,
Tracee.
Congratulations on eight seasons
and I do hope to see you soon.
-Thank you so much, it's lovely
to see you as always.
-Tracee Ellis Ross, everybody.
The final season of "Blackish"
airs Tuesday nights on ABC.